salut aujourd'hui je suis avec mikaël
hirsch bonjour
mikaël hirsch il a un spectacle qui
s'appelle pourquoi pourquoi je te pose
la question pour avoir le nombre ton
spectacle là il s'appelle pourquoi
michael il adore les mots sterckx son
spectacle il est très drôle et il est
intelligent même tambouille on peut le
dire on peut communiquer là dessus que
tu aimes les mots et la langue française
je me suis dit on va faire un petit
scrabble ensemble et moi de scrabble ou
scrabble tu crois en six ans le appelons
ça un scrabble mais un scrabble il ya
ici des lettres dans le scrabble et je
vais te demander de penser à un mot
c'est un jeu de scrabble version de
poche tu connais ou pas non mais c'est
en fait j'ai pas lu les règles tu vois
tu as des lettres dessus et tu dois
penser à un mot qui commence par cette
lettre
ok tu prends ce que tu veux dire c'est
bon ouais donc tu as la lettre et tu
dois penser à un mot qui commence par
cette lettre tu veux te la montre non
parce qu'on pourrait penser que la wii
ne voit dans l'écran de retour et les
mecs en face ils me font pas de calais
on répond par oui ou non dans ta tête
est ce que c'est un objet quelque chose
que je peux toucher quelque chose qui
dise matériellement par an non je ne
répondrai pas pour moi oui c'est quelque
chose que je peux saisir dans ma main je
peux attraper
oui c'est quelque chose qu'ils
rempliraient toute ma main thaddée
bordeaux ne dépend d'aucun d'accord ok
imagine que l'objet devant à cette
taille là peu importe quel tarif est
réellement et que j'essaye de suivre ces
lignes d'accord cette plainte courant
s'est plaint d'arrondi j'ai dû mettre la
gopro pouvoir soviétique ont clairement
dit que c'est un objet qui peut
potentiellement être utile
pour utiliser toute relative je vais
essayer de choper la première lettre de
cet objet tu penses à la première lettre
ça peut être a b c d e f g h et chic
alemanno pq est resté là et mène au fsb
vous devez insultent et choquent pas
encore s en place sur le thème a les
bons coups je vous dis franchement
j'hésite entre deux choses je vous le
pouvez voir avoue tu regardes pas
l'écran je vous fais voir g je vous fais
voir j'hésite entre ces deux choses là
mais je pense puisqu'il écoute
électronique rayon kim validé
inconsciemment celui ci donc j'ai rayé
là pour moi c'est ça est ce que tu peux
nous dire et redire de me dire à quel
moment où tu pensais exactement un
saxophone un saxophone
j'hésitais entre deux choses entre
serpent et saxophone et j'ai rayé
serpent pour garder saxo
oui mickaël hier jean fait bouger la
caméra à la main merci à toi et bravo
belle annonce de bravo à toi de voir je
vais le jeu dans ta tête
je regrette un peu de ne pas avoir mis
la gopro pour avoir des yeux qui
s'écarquillent je sais qu'en tournée en
ce moment là il a grenoble bientôt je
vais à grenoble à la basse cour les deux
prochaines semaines cool on allait le
voir à grenoble à la basse-cour allé le
voir à avignon et sera au festival
d'avignon cet été et je crois qu'avant
avignon tu sera de retour sur paris mais
pour avoir vraiment cette info qu'il va
falloir le suivre sur sa page facebook
parce que là il va tout vous dire ça te
dirait de fernand les hallucinations
collectives ou pas why not
cool pour les hallucinations collectives
sont que des gens atypiques et je
considère que tu fais quelque chose
d'atypique
j'arrive à le dire abonnez-vous à la
chaîne de fabien c'est génial c'est même
pas moi qu'il l'ait dit demain 17h pour
le prochain mentale blog ciao